the core message of your book
uh the price of tomorrow is about
whether or not we
keep on playing the inflation game which
you suggest is baked into our economic
system
as a prerequisite essentially i mean you
know you see you're the federal reserve
and central bank say all the time we
have an inflation target
you know it's uh not too high
but also not zero it's got to be a
positive number
inflation is exactly the same thing as
wage deflation
it's the opposite side of the coin so in
other words to try to create more jobs
you're paying people less
in real terms and you can see the
political divide you can see the haves
and haves knots getting worse and worse
and worse caused by the same thing with
different
actors on both sides of the system
saying i'll fix it without realizing the
root cause of the problem we believe we
need inflation
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks technology entrepreneur
extraordinaire chairman of eight
companies and the author of the price of
tomorrow
one of the i think he was formerly one
of the top ceos to follow on twitter mr
jeff booth
thanks andrew pleasure to be here
it's great to meet you and
congratulations on a really really
thoughtful and incisive book i learned a
lot from it um so first let's fill the
listeners in on who the heck you are
uh what the heck you've done
the sets from reading your book that you
spent years
on a
platform company uh bill direct that was
helping contractors and it seems like
this this job this company was a labor
of love
uh for a number of years but how the
heck did you wind up in that position
and
um how does one even start to become a
technology entrepreneur
[Laughter]
that is interesting well
i'd say what any entrepreneur does
is they take a look at an existing
system that they think doesn't provide
value to somebody else
um and they think they can create a new
business by providing value
so
so to that's really what i did i was
actually a builder before uh before that
technology
company you were a literal builder i was
a literal bill builder so always an
entrepreneur but i was i had a building
company i i owned a real estate company
and and what i realized in the building
company i actually failed to deliver
house on time to people and i put it i
had to put their furniture and storage
them up in a hotel and i was really
i was really
mad
that i was frustrated that i couldn't do
the job i said i could do because the
system was so broken
so i set out to change that and i set
out to change that with technology and
that became
it like you say a labor of love creating
a platform technology technology company
similar to amazon.com
throughout the dot-com crisis and
everything else in in a certain industry
um and from that
building
that's what i set out to do it didn't i
didn't end up there in the end but i but
uh but you you can imagine how much you
learn and learn along the way but that
is what i set out to do
so you have a faint canadian accent uh
and that's
[Laughter]
that's where you hail from uh are you
there now i am i'm here now just outside
of vancouver
oh good for you beautiful part of the
world if anyone has it been um so you
built build direct uh for a number of
years and then it had its trials and
tribulations
how many years ago was that
uh 20 years ago now uh so it started yes
started in well just over 1999.
wow and what the heck has happened since
then
i've learned a lot about myself
technology where the world's going um
what what it means uh and
and one of the things that
kind of into the book my that first
technology company it took five million
dollars of labor or technology people
building technology for something that
is today available for fifty dollars a
month and that uh and so it took about
two years of building that first
technology technology for today fifty
dollars a month and today's version is
way better than what what we built at
that time so how fast technology is
moving people just don't realize what
that looks like
and our brains don't change that fast so
so
so
that just gave me a at a high level um
a whole bunch of structural change that
was happening
um and and at different levels and you
could create a lot of value i do create
a lot of value even today out of out of
different technology companies but
really think about what they do what you
do as an entrepreneur
you only win if you're if you're if
you're valuable to other people
that's how and and today the technology
that allows you to be more valuable to
other people
allows you to win an ever increasing
rate
and so that that that structure
which is deflationary in nature
so it reduces prices and it reduces
prices more and more as people vote to
use services
is hitting up a structure that we've
always lived in which is an inflationary
structure where
we essentially try to make prices go up
through our lives and so so those two
things are incompatible together and i
in and i know you do a lot of work on
what the solution is i i have a
different
version of a solution um but uh but but
but i think we see the world similar in
in where things are going yeah we do
this how we got connected is we're like
book buddies um because people
recommended your book to me and it is an
excellent book the price of tomorrow
uh and we make similar arguments we wind
up in slightly different places
but your argument was a bit different
than mine and i want to unpack what you
just said because i think it's in many
ways the core message of your book
the price of tomorrow
is about whether or not we
keep on playing the inflation game which
you suggest is baked into our economic
system
as a prerequisite essentially i mean you
know you hear the federal reserve and
central bank say all the time we have an
inflation target
you know it's uh not too high
but also not zero it's got to be a
positive number
um and one of the central arguments you
make
is that hey technology is intrinsically
deflationary
where we're getting to do things faster
cheaper
more efficiently
it's going to churn up a lot of jobs
because a lot of people's jobs are born
of various inefficiencies and excess
expenses and so as technology gets
better and better you're going to see
prices naturally want to go down
in a lot of areas
and and andrew one of the things i was
really looking forward to coming on your
show uh to do um i think you're really
thoughtful in this um and and and in
this type of structural change
it requires
really bright people think and instead
of
believing we live in a framework that we
used to live in and papering over an
existing framework
i think it requires critical thought to
how do we transition into a world that
looks very different
because
because if you just follow the track of
technology most of the deflation it's
actually just if you look at your phone
it's everything on your phone is free
and we celebrate that
every one of us votes for getting more
for less out of our individual time it's
actually why we use technology in a
business we try to to make our time more
valuable it's why we use technology
personally we try to make our time more
valuable and we all vote for that every
day
and and today it's moving at an
extraordinary pace way faster than
people know
with
an exponential pace and with with ai
robotics everything else it's going to
accelerate to where people just can't
even relate
um and so if you follow that path
where we're all voting to get more for
less
how can the system be designed to work
exactly the opposite
um where we we all vote with our
individual time to increase our time but
we vote collectively to say somebody
should control making prices go up
for in perpetuity forever well the
argument i made on the presidential
trail was this jeff and this is familiar
to you and you make a similar uh comment
in your book
which is that you have a lot of things
that are getting cheaper or more
available more plentiful
and then there are a few really big
ticket items where prices just go up and
up and unfortunately those things are
making everyone miserable those three
are
housing education and health care the
big three where they're just getting
more and more expensive
even as technology advances and in
america
it's making everyone very sad because
their buying power is staying more or
less the same and then their housing
their education healthcare costs keep
going up but they're like ah like what
is going on why am i so miserable and
then you have in categories like media
clothing
um
[Music]
cars to some extent
most entertainment
um
forms the prices are staying the same or
even going down or the quality is going
up i think cars are staying about the
same price but the quality has gone up a
whole lot um so that so there are
elements
uh where you can see things getting
better and you're getting more bang for
your buck but then the big three
uh occupy most of your mind
okay
so so let's unpack that a little bit
more because i think it's really
critical to this this discussion and
first before we unpack it let's just
imagine this
everything we measure
is from an existing system we don't
measure what a new system could look
like we measure an existing system and
it's actually where why businesses get
trapped in an existing system too
blockbuster measures how many people
come into their stores and they don't
measure how fast netflix is moving and
then a change in technology changes the
game and all the stories become
irrelevant and instead of thinking about
what how fast technology's moving what
they do is is add candy aisles to their
stores thinking that they'll change
change things
the same thing we do
right so i use that example because it's
important that we we look at blockbuster
execs and think how could they miss
technology moving so fast yet we do it
in our lives every day it's what we do
so we we're in a system measuring things
gdp to always go up and that system is
being manipulated through inflation by
printing money to make prices always go
up
and so we don't we don't ask the
question so so today there's 250
trillion actually there's more today
when i wrote the book 250 trillion
dollars of global debt to run an 80
trillion dollar global economy and you
would think could that debt ever be paid
back
probably not those are huge numbers but
maybe maybe we find some other
industries that we could grow faster
but when you examine it deeper what you
realize is 185 trillion dollars of that
250 trillion dollars of debt came in the
last 20 years
and then we failed to recognize that
would our houses actually have gone up
in value
if you didn't
stimulate them by 185 trillion dollars
globally over the last 20 years and the
answer is simply no
neither would education neither would
anything else
so now you run into now you start to see
the problem and you start to see
if somebody controls money and they can
constantly control money
then some people win out of that
economic equation and some people lose
and you would you destroy the free
market by doing so so
this this is one of the big arguments
you make which uh the math you know is
very compelling when you say look what
we've been doing is we've been juicing
growth by printing a lot of money but
it's by pumping up debt
and the numbers you just cited are
saying that we're not actually getting
that much growth
exactly for all the debt we're taking
out it's going into stores of value it's
going into what would you do what it
would a rational actor do
if peop if you're printing that much
money and what would happen a rational
actor would put more money into real
estate to try to try to to try to get
away from that printing
rational actors would i need to get into
the best schools and i'm i have more
money than those other people so i need
to get into those because it's my only
way to get out of this system and try
and so what you're doing is you're
pushing prices up
rent prices are going up more and more
people are left out
and and those people are coming back to
the same government whether no matter
what side of the aisle you're on the
same government saying
we need you to fix this problem
but the problem is a structural problem
and it's not bad people in on either
side it's they're both dealing from a
structural issue
that can't be solved by the same
structure
system change can't come from the system
that created the problem
[Music]
i found this argument really
fascinating um
and most of it's incontrovertible like
you know we have printed a lot of money
no i i will say that
um
my sense of why prices have gone up
um in education and healthcare it's not
just that we've produced a lot of
currency
it's that the institutions
uh aren't actually driven to become more
efficient um where they're they're being
driven to just make more money and in
both those industries if you're a
hospital you decide to ratchet the
prices up then it just gets passed along
to consumers who feel like they don't
have a choice but to pay because it's
not like you have an alternative
healthcare system to go to uh and the
same is true for college tuition
where every year the colleges look up
and say how much we can increase the
prices by this year but you know and and
so that has
um added up over time
um
and so when i was making this argument
to folks on the trail it was like look
these institutions just aren't really
price uh
uh they're not
negotiating on price because they think
that you
as the consumer don't have a choice so
you're not price sensitive let me jump
into that one specifically because i
think it'll create it'll change it might
change a whole bunch of people's minds
on this thing now remember our minds
once we believe in something are hard to
change
they're really so we'll kind of keep on
reinforcing
reinforcing our beliefs instead of
objectively looking at the facts
but here's a fact
education is already free
it's already free it's
um it's it's certification is not and
why we
stay in that system is we believe we'll
get a better job higher paying job by by
staying in that system but but
and i've hired thousands of people and i
can tell you um the curious driven
person
that is always learning
that is finding their way to
learn i would hire
almost
100 times out of 100 over somebody that
just thinks i got an education now i'm
done
and and so
so if you with an internet connection
you could learn you could get to any phd
uh professor you could learn anything on
anything it's not just certification
though jeff because check it out like i
agree with you that look i can access
the the content the the learning yeah um
but and you have kids right i have three
kids yeah yeah are they college age
they're one's just getting into college
yeah
yeah
so if you look at the average 18 year
old as to why they're going to college
here's here's the um the sense i have
most of them
could not tell you about
all of the
different
courses uh that they uh plan on taking
or the professors
they pick a school one because of the
credentialing you speak of uh because
everyone will just say hey uva great
school um but there's also the
socialization that takes place
um and then there's the network that
takes place because they'll be friends
with all these other uva grads uh and
then education in terms of like the book
learning and whatnot is somewhere in
there
um
along with like a whole suite of other
value ads
so so the content anyone can you know
probably just go on by a textbook you
know and then and the rest of it but uh
but it's not just credentialing it's
like this whole suite of other things i
totally agree with you and my daughter
it's not just that too i want to go have
fun right i want to meet a whole yeah
like some of it's partnering so it's
like i want you know like people some
people will go to business school
because they you know they're looking to
find a partner i guess what i'm getting
at is a monopoly believes it has power
forever and doesn't have to change well
technology's moving the other way and
technology has changed the rules of what
that looks like
and and today
some people are just waking up to that
change
and i would
i would say
over time as school prices get higher
and higher and higher
and more and more value accretes to to
people who can learn on their own we
will see we are beliefs will change
around around school and as they change
around school
they um that takes a whole other
industry out of
rising prices now we could argue that
before yeah here's where it gets
interesting like i have friends you
probably have some of the same friends
who have been trying to innovate in
education for quite some time saying you
know what like i can provide the same
thing for you know have the price um
minerva comes to mind um chronically is
working on another one sorry khan
academy
oh yeah khan academy is like the very
high level
um
free-ish one that that helps uh people
learn all over the world um and
these things have not
disrupted college in the way that anyone
had imagined in part because
and again if you look at your own
experience if but you know if i have two
boys they're not college age yet um but
i kind of expect them to go to college
[Laughter]
but it's funny that you say that now by
the way that we could go down this
rabbit hole forever it because this is a
belief change and and i think you're
right right now but i but i would say
over time those beliefs change and they
change because the market
creates a it creates a different way of
going what happens is you have a handful
of really mavericky young people whom i
love who look up and say hey i don't
need like all the fancy buildings and
the rest of it like i wouldn't i wish
one
yeah that could have been you
um and then you'll have some people who
are locked out of
the traditional system or
uh you know
think it's a terrible value
but for a lot of families if they have
the ability to go
um they'll try and send their kids
to college because
uh you know it's what they did or it's
what all of the kids around their kids
are doing or you know you know or
a lot of it will be for um the social
aspect um and so anyway i don't want to
take us too far uh down a digression
here um but you and i finally agree with
with uh uh you know on a lot of these
things
um and i also would agree with you on
uh
the fact that a lot of asset
values uh real estate would be maybe the
most prominent um but i would say
uh stock prices would be another
there are various assets um that are
being inflated in price um in part
because we just have so much money in
the system well when you have when you
have blackrock essentially an agent of
the government
buying uh
buying houses against population
you can see pushing prices up so they're
competing in the open housing market for
for houses you can see what's happening
so that concentration of wealth the more
assets you have and the more printing
you do those prices just go up and and
and then what ends up happening out of
that system so if if you think about
that system that system
is is
so we don't see it because we measure
the system our daily lives are measuring
the system but food prices go up asset
prices go up everything else all the
food in a whole bunch of people
inflation is exactly the same thing as
wage deflation it's the opposite side of
the coin so in other words to try to
create more jobs you're paying people
less
in real terms
and and and their income in their
savings are going down in real-time in
real terms and you one and we wonder why
we have conflict
growing conflict all over the world it's
caused by that exact same thing
but but then people come up to
and and and you can see the political
divide you can see the haves and the
haves knots getting worse and worse and
worse caused by the same thing with
different
actors on both sides of the system
saying i'll fix it without realizing the
root cause of the problem
[Music]
so we agree on that fundamental dynamic
which is really really deep
what you're saying is look you control
the money supply you produce more money
who wins
uh people with assets people who who can
take advantage of price appreciation who
loses people who are just trading their
labor for money because that money just
gets worth less and less over time
because they can't buy as much with it
we completely agree there
yeah and and then you believe and i
agree
that this is going to drive political
unrest
look at signposts they're everywhere
yeah and this is the argument i made
running for president i said look trump
is a symptom not the disease uh he's a
symptom of an economy that has left
millions of people behind and they're
just getting more and more ticked off
and
it's worse in some of the
traditional swing states that democrats
used to win and now are losing like
ohio and iowa
pennsylvania uh we you know i think um
was a toss up and i think narrowly went
blue um so there so the the effects of
um
wage deflation as you call it and then i
i was making an automation argument um
but that their
forces that are pushing in the same
direction
are going to end up driving our politics
in various ways keep going keep going
though because i totally agree and so
now we are on a
one thing people think about is ai one
day we'll have it one day one day we
won't have it one day we'll have it and
it doesn't work like that it's on a on a
trend and that trend that you're talking
about
or robotics that trend on robotics or 3d
printing or or or all of these things or
energy that trend
um is further it means most of the
deflation
is in front of us and so if it took 185
trillion dollars of stimulus to stop it
then then it requires exponentially more
over and over and over
um to be able to it's so so what we're
seeing now is just the tip of the
iceberg of what we will see on this path
yes i will say your book made me want to
run out and
try and hedge against inflation in any
way you can um i just got off the phone
uh
with a friend who had just launched an
etf
uh called infl which is a hedge against
inflation and he says hey we're doing
great
and one one thing
one thing i think inside the argument
because it is a d
it is a deep thesis and again we're
measuring a system so
a lot of times we won't even look at
this because we don't want it to be true
but it is true
now inside inside that
there's a there's a couple of layers to
that
we think about inflation measuring off
zero
what if the disinflationary
power of technology 20 years ago was
negative one percent that's what the
economy is is
your time freed up
and you got more and more for less and
less and then what if today
it's negative five percent because
technology is moving faster and faster
on a trend
so then two or three or five percent
inflation would look like a way bigger
theft
it would look like because all inflation
is is it's it is a theft it's i'm going
to steal your money
and give it to somebody else it's robin
hood and reverse
um and and i wish that wasn't true
but it is um and and so what if
um what if our actual system underneath
is actually getting more and more
disinflationary more inflationary and so
but we are not measuring it we're
measuring it off zero
then what would look like inflation of
two percent would be a greater conflict
to the world
i hear what you're saying that the base
rate maybe you look at it as like minus
two percent so then there's two percent
inflation it's like really four
compounding
so one one of the
observations you make which was
interesting uh we said look you have a
limited number of options if you are in
the situation you are in and you're a
government uh number one is austerity
you you
you stop
spending money
number two is
you print more money
uh
and then uh and then if you're a
government
um
austerity is very unappealing
so
your logical thing to do is is number
two
uh number three is redistribution
um which some people listening to this
will be very excited by
um and i as you know like i'm for
universal basic income i think there are
ways to do it where it's not terribly
punitive and i think that the money that
goes into the hands of people at the
bottom would end up
um
doing a lot of good like in very good
places and then there was a fourth
option um which is uh what was the
fourth option
it typically comes through revolution
and war uh yes the one i forgot
revolutionary war
so so you can see why
uh a government chooses to print if
those are the options um and i think the
subtext of your book was that eventually
you wind up with a revolution over uh at
least that was a suggestion i got yeah
and and this is
why i wrote the book is is
i want for anything that doesn't happen
i want to most peace a peaceful reset i
want a system that will work into the
future in perpetuity
and and so
let's look at that and and so
so
and let's why don't we examine ubi from
from
actually before we do that
let's let's start with climate change
right so there's a there's a bunch of
people which with a cognitive dissonance
that that said so technology is is
driving prices cheaper and cheaper and
cheaper and a lot of that technology is
green we get more for less let's use
solar energy is so it's wanting to make
energy prices cheaper and everything we
have is on top of those energy prices
and so you have more and it's getting
cheaper by about 11 per year as it moves
into more parts of the industry
so what you could expect what you could
deduct from that is
everything is going to get cheaper
but if you live in an inflationary
environment where everything has to get
more expensive
or the entire system collapses
then you have to keep printing money so
you keep
us human beings as rats on wheels
running faster and faster needing two
jobs driving back and forth for two jobs
to work faster and faster and faster at
an ever increasing velocity
to try to to stop that deflationary
force to keep the system in check
and that
inflation equals climate change
so so and i know that's a big deal and i
know it's a bit but but there is no way
to solve there is no way to solve
climate change through a system that
must grow forever on a finite planet and
will and will debase currency to do it
[Music]
there's some really big ideas
into this and kind of why i was telling
was looking forward to talking to you is
is you're thoughtful on a whole bunch of
okay we understand the problem
and as an entrepreneur what i think
about is once i understand the problem
all energy should go into what are the
best possible solutions out of that
and and thinking about okay what is a
solution
okay so now take take that and let's
take
so ubi
um essentially
to me at least right now
on top of an existing system
what it does is it says we're still in
an inflationary world
but a whole bunch of people are hurting
we're going to make that go faster by
printing more money
to hold prices higher and higher and
higher so that we get to decide who who
just who uh who gets what i i'm not sure
that
giving everyone a certain amount of
money
necessarily then says and we're gonna
have everything get more expensive
because i agree with you ideally you
would have innovations like solar that
decrease the
uh
that you know decrease the cost of a lot
of things
my ideal world of universal basic income
is actually very minimalist
where people are getting a certain
amount of money and i've seen this in
real life where some people if they get
a passive income at a certain level they
just hang out in the woods
so so that by the way that's actually
the funny thing that we actually agree
on we agree that that technology saves
our time and we could do uh do a uh we
would
prices would fall and the world we're
measuring is a completely arbitrary
world because of printing money that's
where we agree with and if you actually
lowered your time preference and said
what would actually happen
we can't measure that world right now
because prices are going up and when
prices keep going up no matter who makes
them go up
and this is actually why it's not a
political i'm not on either side of the
aisle or anything else this is not a
political statement this is a statement
for my kids
that that we need a different system
otherwise i think our world burns
and it's not just a us
phenomenon this phenomenon you can see
actually going all over the world
yeah the big argument you make in the
book i believe there are a couple big
arguments you make it's why i enjoyed it
so much
but one is that we have to stop being
addicted to inflation we have to start
allowing for deflation but just so much
of our system right now is predicated on
prices going up a certain amount that if
you allow for deflation and it is true
that
uh if you had deflation it would be seen
as a massive policy failure right now
um and and
so to carry that forward and now what
what potential so if you had there
there's about 120 trillion dollars
globally of negatively negative real
interest bonds
and so what ends up happening is so so
that's a risk-free rate of all global
trade and everything else and it's not a
the risk-free rate is negative so if if
money is corrupted at the base layer
then you could expect corruption
everywhere as a result
and that and and that's that's what's
happening so as a policy
how could you let's say let's say we
agree
and andrew yang's going to
try to be president next
how could you say it's impossible to say
okay we should go for deflation
because because what allowing deflation
would do on a credit-based system is the
assets would keep on unwinding
they would keep
they'd kee and and and the price and and
because the real debt would explode and
everybody holding the debt which is
largely government and corporations and
everybody else and all the people on top
would get you might as well light a fire
because all of the prices would reset
and the entire system would collapse and
the government would be forced to come
in and nationalize banks
and so now that's actually why this is a
big deal because how do you transition
from one system
that that worked for a long time that we
believe in
but doesn't work with where we're going
as a species
as human humanity how do you transition
between systems
and um
and
and and that and so you need a
transmission mechanism to allow that to
happen and that transmission mechanism
that needs to be a global transmission
mechanism it can't be
one government one because because you
couldn't do it as just the us or euro or
canada and anything else it needs to be
a global phenomenon
so you don't make this argument that
explicitly in your book though it is
included
is that it it seemed like you're a huge
bitcoin and cryptocurrency
uh
believer and proponent as a result
because you're looking at it saying look
we have these currencies that are being
uh printed in various ways and and
governments are going to keep on
succumbing to the
the incentives that they have
um so you need a new currency that they
can't do that to and let's call it
bitcoin the supply is
uh capped
you know like even if you wanted to you
couldn't make more
so
so andrew i've come to that conclusion
and more as a result of research book
and everything else and and essentially
putting on my entrepreneur hat and and
going down every rabbit hole possible
on what could what is the best possible
path to abundance for humanity
that's really what i uh what
so so yes i become a big bitcoin
proponent
um but i could care less
about making money on bitcoin i could
care less
um i i care about the the world in which
my children grew up in
and and and and and so
i know that sounds and it's going to
sound for a lot of your listeners like
oh don't you just flip the tables on a
system now these people have money and
everything else but the system remember
we can't measure what a system would
look like
from the system we're in
and so people aren't doing the work on
what that system would look like
and and that system would look like
prices keep coming down lower and lower
and lower forever
we believe that economics and we believe
we need inflation everybody just quite a
unilaterally doesn't question why
so we believe our money must be worth
less each year to live in a productive
city
society it makes no sense but we believe
it and so it carries on
um uh
and and this
this allows that change from one system
to another and in if a whole bunch of
people
start engaging in it and if you saw
if you saw how fast that ecosystem is is
evolving
then then it could provide prosperity
for a whole bunch of people throughout
that and the system looks different in
that so what the system looks like in
that is as labor is removed prices fall
as labor's removed prices fall and it
keeps on so you can't
control pricing by arbitrary changing
units and pushing
money into some people's pockets at the
expense of others so as labor if we
believe that technology is moving fast
is faster and faster which you and i do
and labor at some time is going to be
coming out we're not going to get net
new jobs all over the or
the world
then you must also
i to me
advocate for a digitally native currency
that allows deflate for deflation
and and because that won't come from
government because governments can't do
it because if they said that we're all
in on bitcoin the existing system would
collapse
you need a transition mechanism to a new
system that allows for abundance so i
understand all sides of the coin
of of of what this looks like but you
but but it needs to be kind of a global
system
that allows this to this to happen and
it's that big a deal
what proportion of cryptocurrency
enthusiasts do you think come at it the
same way that you do because a lot of
them and you just said it's like hey
look i don't care about getting rich on
this stuff
like
but i think a lot of people are in the
um
uh in the crypto community in part
because
uh they've
realized so much uh appreciation and
wealth gains
so that's it and and i think some of
those people
make other people wanting to learn what
it looks like
harder it's why i do what i do kind of
trying to come at it from first
principles and really understand kind of
where we are in in this
and i i specifically don't say other
cryptocurrencies because other
cryptocurrencies
there's so much noise around them
because because they can be controlled
they look like a company
so instead of bitcoin with it which is
truly
decentralized just distributed why
that's why that's important and uh and
really important is
wealth doesn't mean anything on bitcoin
you have no more power by having more
wealth
and what that means is if you tried to
aggregate for control let's say you
tried to control people through your
bitcoin
what that means but by control you'd be
giving up your bitcoin you'd be
lessening your control
over time
so so it works an entirely different way
than to today's world
looks once you have control you
essentially political lobbying and
everything else and you aggregate more
and more more more and more control
looks very different
than a system that that that
the way you actually add more bitcoin in
time
is is providing more value to other
people
and and and what and you just read this
in the book but we measure economics by
scarcity by by value when it is in fact
in scarcity
so the error you breathe
if it was valuable then it should be the
most expensive thing you um in your
world because it's your most valuable
thing and if we wanted to create jobs
there we could hire a whole bunch of
people to bring us around arab oxygen
masks
the only place
in the
mountains kidding
i was uh in colorado in the mountains
and i did buy
flavored oxygen at like a 7-11 and it
was delicious
where it's first where it's scarce you
buy you buy it you buy it on everest and
you buy it underwater and it just kind
of proves that point and what's ending
up happening is technology is making
more and more things abundant and
and and this is going to be hard for
people that aren't following
again i'm at the leading edge of this
and artificial intelligence and robotics
i see it what's most people who listen
to me
agree that technology is going to come
for us all
yeah exactly and so so so that's that
that piece then that then most things
turn into oxygen yeah amen you know i
mean that there
there are a lot of entrenched interests
that will fight it tooth and nail to
your point which is like look i've got a
billion dollar franchise charging you
lots of money for this stuff
totally and and why and why system
change
rarely comes from the system
system change is imposed through
technology think and trying to deliver
more value to to other people if you
just if you just think about what
bitcoin is
and why it's growing on a network effect
that fast and what's happening on that
system you could just look at that's
what it is
it's a system change and why people
don't see it is they're doing the same
thing they did with the internet in 1996
they're projecting the current use of
the internet
forward instead of where it'll be
there are some
themes i think that most people are
sensing which is that
we have
a lot of change in the air
we have a lot of institutions that are
going to resist that change in part
because
they make a very handsome living
the current situation
there are certain sub industries where
that will not work where the the old
company will have to make way for the
new
but there are a lot of
industries where that's not happening
where you don't see that sort of
replacement
um and i'm going to call out again
education healthcare housing as like
that the three big examples another
example you could throw in there is
politics itself like you're not seeing a
lot of
dynamism where you have
an entrenched duopoly of two parties
that have been
and you should know listening to this
that
there's nothing in the constitution
about two parties it's actually a bit of
a nightmare
the perspective of the founders
but it's hard to manufacture change
um and so
the big theme about how the system can't
amend itself
and that change has to happen from
outside the system
uh i think makes perfect sense
and and and and
because
think about this and from again i and i
and i try to say this all the time
inside the system there are really good
people
um you
i would say a really good person trying
to advocate for change we disagree on
the solution potentially and i don't
actually disagree that there might
doesn't need to be a social safety net
on the way through on the other side
i would just like that social safety net
not to be hidden from me in inflation
pretending
to say
um one thing because inflation
is a hidden theft so i would rather
governments get elected on the truth on
a new system and here's the taxes that
need to go and we've
people vote for it rather than
rather than
being hidden from me but both both
systems at their base
whether it's republican or democrat
require endless more printing
so so then everything becomes on top of
that system i believe in the free market
it's not a free market
it's not a free market if so
like you just said housing goes up and
rent prices go up it's it's it's not a
free market when you're distorting
that much money
corrupting that much money to make those
housing prices go up it's a function of
the system
and so so you need a new system because
the system unfortunately can't change
itself
so that i think was one of the big
lessons from the price of tomorrow um
you're a very practical constructive uh
enterprising
person what would you recommend to
people listening to this if they want to
understand what's going on i would say
your book uh is excellent and readable
um and might be some place that that
that they want to start um and i i can
sense that you wrote this book really
just because you wanted people to have a
different lens of the world like there
there was nothing to it
i don't i don't need to sell i i don't
need to sell more books
yeah no you're just trying to do good i
can sense it um but one one of the
lessons i got was like wow you know i
should really be thinking about
um putting
savings into things that can't just be
inflated away
that was one thing i thought but like
like what what do you recommend so
andrew on i would recommend
and i would never go say go buy bitcoin
for for everybody to but i would
recommend people definitely learn about
it and why it's important and not just
at the at the their natural response to
say
this and push it away or those people
are self-promoting and everything else
understand at a deeper level why it's
important
and then if you understand at a deeper
level of why it's important get off zero
and then
here's what makes me hopeful because
your next book and what you're talking
about american politics and global
politics and and and all of these things
that are coming down the line from the
existing system
it's like reading signposts and if you
know where this is going you can read
all of the tea leaves of what's coming
next
and and so what i would say in that is
dig deeper
and then if you understand bitcoin for
what it could be
then
then earlier people on bitcoin just like
if you invested in amazon at five
dollars
um will do better
but actually that's not so so you have
yourself interested in an earlier
country advocating for a bitcoin will do
better than other countries
and
and and um but
but
and then if you understand the policy
around it and what that means is
essentially
where we're moving with technology
requires a
digitally native digi
currency that allows for deflation
every other policy
concentrates wealth and privilege faster
and concentrates all
all control so if you understand what
that is then you look at the the types
of opportunities that could could allow
you to transition in that and i see only
bitcoin
being able to do it do that i might be
wrong people need to say okay i might be
wrong with everything else and do their
own research but that's the only thing
that i see doing that and so why i
advocate for it is because it is because
it's that important
you can also follow jeff booth i've been
following him and have been learning a
lot thank you so much jeff and we're
going to keep working on this because
your kids and my kids aren't going
anywhere and we still have to try and
keep this world from burning
love that
love that
[Music]
you